I have a really important case study for
you today about how Republicans end up
muddying the waters and winning merely
by distracting as you probably know
Donald Trump has been impeached we have
an impeached president only the third in
the history of the United States we are
now standing by for the Senate trial
which will begin when House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi sends the impeachment
articles that the House approved over to
the Senate an acquittal is all but a
foregone conclusion in the
republican-controlled Senate I've talked
about how it could go differently it's
not likely to go differently this is all
about Donald Trump but Republicans have
been able to turn this around and make
it about Joe Biden during the last week
Democratic primary candidate and former
VP Joe Biden said to the Des Moines
Register last week he would not comply
if the Senate subpoenas him to the
impeachment trial of Donald Trump in the
Senate now Joe Biden accurately told the
newspaper that sending a subpoena to Joe
Biden would be a way to take attention
off of Trump and that part he was right
about but then he said that he wouldn't
comply and of course Joe Biden is right
that's subpoenaing him to the
impeachment trial would be an attempt to
distract from Donald Trump but
immediately Republicans respond with how
could this be Biden would ignore a
subpoena even though Democrats won't
stop talking about how Republicans are
ignoring subpoenas and they're terrible
because of it does Joe Biden not care
about the Constitution which is obvious
concern trolling but it pushes the story
to being about Biden instead of being
about Trump so then this leads to
another round of Biden talking about
this having to clarify Biden a few days
later had to go back and say oh but hold
on of course I would obey a legal
constitutional subpoena tweeting about
it in addition to talking about it
saying on Twitter quote I want to
clarify something I said yesterday in my
40 years in public life I have always
complied with a lawful order and in my
eight years as VP my office unlike
Donald Trump and Mike Pence cooperated
with legitimate congressional oversight
requests but I am NOT just going to
pretend
that there is any legal basis for
Republican subpoenas for my testimony in
the impeachment trial that is the point
I was making yesterday and I reiterate
this impeachment is about Trump's
conduct not mine the subpoenas should go
to witnesses with testimony to offer to
Trump's shaking down the Ukraine
government so now it gets more muddled
with commentary about the commentary Joe
Biden said he wouldn't comply then he
said of course he would comply but what
I mean is it wouldn't make any sense to
subpoena me Republicans are great at
this and Biden stepped in it what Biden
should have said from day one is this
impeachment trial has nothing to do with
me any attempt to pull me into it would
be an attempt to distract of course I
believe in the Constitution and the rule
of law and I will always do what is
legally required of me but the idea that
I should be part of this Senate trial is
a political strategy make to meant to
make impeachment about me instead of
about Donald Trump he didn't say that
instead he sort of tried to be tough I
won't go but that's the wrong thing to
say he has to walk it back they are
experts in experts in this they won't
even fight the substance they distract
misdirect they get Democrats to argue
with themselves we've got to be smarter
we can't be falling for this stuff and
Joe Biden did remember that tomorrow
January 1 big membership special going
out by email
an obscene discount an opportunity for
you to put your name on the record as a
supporter of the David Pakman show for
2020 it's an election year this stuff
matters get on our newsletter by signing
up at david pakman.com and then tomorrow
you'll get an email with instructions
for how to take advantage of this it's
it's so cheap it's disgustingly obscene
the membership special we're running
tomorrow do you feel like you just don't
have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that there are just not
enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription
when you go to blink is comm slash
Pakman what blink is does is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work
I've just finished listening to upheaval
by Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a
tremendous author whose work I've
previously recommended excellent book
looking at some of modern history's
biggest national crises to figure out
how different countries ended up in such
precarious situations Blinky's has
totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for bling cast
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video